ein tag essen wie in ghana steht heute
auf dem programm ist haben sich so viele
von euch gewünscht ich habe beim letzten
mal drei länder zur abstimmung gegeben
und ghana hat einfach alles gesprengt
der kommentar für ghana hatte mehr likes
als das video also komplett krank wir
sind deshalb heute ein tag wie in ghana
bleibt dann bis zum ende der da gibt es
wieder drei länder zur abstimmung los
geht es mit dem frühstück und damit
fangen wir an mit unserem frisch es gibt
heute morgen sugar break ich muss mich
wirklich einmal kurz zu positionieren
ich habe gar nicht ganz wenig an von
ganesha küche und möchte die man auch
die füße treten indem ich irgendwas
nicht authentisch machen oder so hat so
gut wie ich konnte recherchiert ich
hoffe dass ich das alles wollte richtig
man die schuhfabrik wird häufig auf dem
weg zur arbeit in die schule wie auch
immer an einen straßenstand gekauft und
dann ist man das einfach so ohne
weiteres auch häufig so werde ich heute
auch machen sie benötigen dafür 500
gramm mehl 2 esslöffel milch pulver und
die geben wir jetzt einmal durch dieses
sieht hierhin durch relativ leicht
relativ simpel mit sugar ray wenn das
hier einmal durch gesiebt ist geht es
schon weiter und ich sage euch es wird
nicht unbedingt schwieriger ein wir
werden jetzt hier unsere schüssel mit
dem durch gesiebte mehl vesper in der
mitte eine kleine schule machen ergeben
wir unser 1 1 jetzt auch
gegenüberliegenden seiten ein essen das
walken tiefe was wir jetzt mit relativ
vielen anderen seite gute prise sei zwar
derzeit eben nicht die vertreten soll
direkt gegeben dann noch 45 gramm butter
dazu und ganz wichtig für sugar brett
natürlich auch zucker 100 gramm also ein
halber fehlt nur noch eine zutat nämlich
wasser 150 milliliter die wir auch dazu
einmal drüber den rest der arbeit
erledigt unsere maschinen uns einfach
mit knethaken ausstatten das anstellen
und erst mal fünf minuten kneten lassen
nach fünf minuten schalten wir unsere
maschine aus 45 und diesen prozess
wieder haben wir viermal also insgesamt
20 minuten neben 20 minuten und so sieht
das ganze nach 40 minuten aus erteilt
hatten wir eine sehr sehr schöne
konsistent zu bekommen und auch total
viel widerstand aufgebaut aber klebt
trotzdem nicht so sehr an den händen
gewesen deshalb bin ich sehr zufrieden
wir machen jetzt einen komischen muff
potter dieser arbeitsfläche anstelle sie
zunehmend die absolut komisch an butter
auf meine hände noch dass sie überhaupt
nichts denken und dann wollen wir einmal
gebraucht so sieht ja ganz so aus das
ist jetzt genug material für zwei rote
papier ich dass mein und wir verlieren
nach augen einfach ein bisschen so gut
aus sieht wirklich gut aus er sieht
verein so schön fertig jetzt auch mit
der ganzen butter noch und jetzt haben
wir uns eine für holz wird dann auch das
und dann beginnen wir das ganze
vorsichtig ausgerollt und sie das ist
das funktioniert wirklich sehr sehr gut
macht auch genau das was er soll außer
durch zusammen ende wo keine butter ist
ein bisschen anzukleben jetzt nehmen wir
den einfachen zeiten die ein bisschen
zusammen sagt dienten die sie noch in
rollen den ein wenig dass wir einfach so
eine schöne geschlossene folge haben die
wir dann in unsere formen geben können
und siehe da unsere petrol ist fertig
vor mir die noch ein bisschen und hätten
wir sofort ein spannend weil ich das
ganze auf leben muss und in die voll
hinein denken muss hier dringend für
mich noch ein bisschen nach vorn so
sieht das ganze aus was decken jetzt
einmal ab erlauben den ganzen bin ich
einfach ein bisschen zu gehen da muss
ich das ganze in den ofen stellen welche
flächen dem termin habe aber ich freue
mich schon sehr darauf zu freuen und das
brot ist mittlerweile nach einer halb
schon verdoppelt so großmann sieht
richtig geil wie es hier richtig so
schön hoch gegangen ist und so kommt es
jetzt in den backofen für ungefähr 30
minuten und wenn's goldbraun ist nach
ungefähr 15 minuten tun wir
aluminiumfolie drüber damit es nicht zu
grauen wird es ist wieder da da bin ich
wieder leute wohnen das brot jetzt
heraus
wie schon gesagt ist das ganze ab
geweckt haben damit weiter breun
zweiter schwede immer mehr richtig so
vom gefühl her dass das echt super soft
super ist es mit entweder gar nichts
oder mit mutter das zweite ist die
sugarbabes klassisch in kastenform aber
so große freude aus statt noch mal
machen heute kommen
eigentlich würde man das ganze jetzt
noch ohne dass aber ich kann es wirklich
nicht mehr erwarten rhein zu schneiden
ich habe einfach durch hunger hat sich
jetzt aber noch mal deutlich gesetzt
also es ist schon wichtig nicht sofort
gucken wir uns mal gemeinsam dies
geworden ist weil
ja aber er ist kein spaß ich wende gar
keinen druck an mit dem messer wir
probieren unser sugar braid selbst
gebacken ohne alles
hmm das geht nicht so in die richtung
von so einem teig unserem psychischen
hörnchen tranken wir das ganze mal
mitnehmen wir ihr und unserem break
holen wir uns hier ein stückchen
abschneiden das ganze ein wenig an ist
nehmen wir uns reicht das brot kommt es
einfach in die mitte und schließen das
ganze und das ist eine weitere
klassische zubereitungsart braucht man
auch ein bisschen mehr substanz für den
tag
[Musik]
schnelles einfaches frühstück
grundsätzlich müssten in ghana so dass
immer eine steigerung im laufe des tages
zuvor herrscht also leichtes frühstück
kleines prüfe mittleres mittagessen und
dann ein schönes abendessen darauf freue
ich mich jetzt schon aber wir machen wir
jetzt erstmal das mittags und wir kommen
zum mittagessen ich habe alles hier
stehen bist du mit schippen und reis
sehr sehr lecker vom da alles was wir
haben steht hier wir brauchen nur ein
bisschen zeit so wir nehmen uns unsere
zwiebeln große grob geschnittenen
zwiebeln die geben wir in einem mix
ankum für die werbung
nicht die hälfte nebenbei dazu kommt
jetzt eine havanna erstmal den stil
davon ab und eine grüne ihr werdet euch
denken sowieso cocktails mit brühwürfel
was mit ihm passiert ja auch hier wieder
ein rezept befolgt welches ich euch
verlinken werde so gehen mir das ganz
auf jeden fall erst im nachhinein umfang
an das ganze zu kommen natürlich nicht
irgendwie oder mit irgendwas mit salat
von es gibt diesen wechsel und ganz ganz
viele andere dinge 5 prozent günstiger
mit dem korb 5 max 5 schaut gern mal
vorbei damit unterstützt ihr mich und
mein partner co da gibt es übrigens
nicht nur mixa es gibt dort auch
trockenfrüchte nüsse dass es zum
beispiel gerne esse ich habe das
wirklich zu hause zum beispiel in
pohritzsch von coro zum frühstück der
andere ich bin sehr dankbar dass
chronische unterstützt deshalb tut mir
und ihnen eingefallen und schaut mal
vorbei wir müssen das ganze dass daraus
eine paste entsteht die noch tiefer
unseres einzieht und glaube ich sehr
sehr lecker wird
auf jeden fall bin ich noch nicht da
sind wir uns einig okay wir geben erst
mal unser chicken hinter dem topf ich
hab das rezept von bay ist food ist eine
unglaublich in deutschland leben ich bin
mir sicher so wie das auch sagt kann
google kann nur kurz möglich ist so ein
ganz anderer ansatz komplett wir dieses
ortes schicken drüber und jetzt geben
wir über 300 milliliter wasser und so
wie es hier ist kochen wir das ganze
jetzt für 40 minuten die restlichen
zwiebeln geben wir jetzt ebenfalls in
den mixer und unsere andere chili
erst dadurch fünf sekunden mit dem
exakten ein wenig salz dran die hälfte
hier und die andere hälfte hier jetzt
gehen wir hier etwa 100 milliliter höhle
in die familien ist auf jeden fall der
ganze topf kunden gut bedeckt ist das
lassen wir jetzt heiß werden sobald es
heißt es eben ja so müssen wir eben mit
unseren rechtlichen zwiebeln chili
hinein und so kritieren oder werbe
medizin jetzt gold frauen also wer das
ganze bekommt ihn wir unsere mädchen in
den mixer und polen
das jetzt wird es zeit in dem die brücke
und wir bröseln sie aus unserer hand da
hinein
das team richtig aus dem auto lief gut
aus da gehen jetzt die formate lassen
wir das ganze jetzt schön lange
einkommen etwa auch so 40 hier kommt
alles schön vor sich hin wollen das
ganze jetzt mal hier raus ist auf jeden
fall schon vorgedacht wir werden gleich
aber noch in extra schritt gehen und das
ganze frittieren einfach weil es noch
mal mehr geschmack gibt und nur schöne
knusprige textur und fried chicken
generell sind einfach es ist oft so wir
haben das rechtzeitig gestoppt gehen mir
wenig von der brühe wir hier haben wir
während unseres du einfach nach gefühl
ist natürlich jetzt feinst hühnerbrühe
also sagen dass öl ist heißt wir geben
das chicken hinein und bisher ist erst
in gold braun ich gebe es nicht direkt
hinüber sein dass sie bis zu acht toten
habe das gleiche wiederholende mit den
anderen kirchen dies ist durch dieses
wunderbar zitierte checken das nehmen
wir so wie es und geben es hinein in
unsere street ihren sorgt dafür dass es
nicht zerfällt lädt das stimmt nur von
öl das wird auch mit tief roten farbe so
werden jetzt alles hineingucken das
alles nochmal bedeckt ist das noch mal
final 20 minuten kochen wir nehmen uns
zunächst empfehle ich von unserem
reichen land
jetzt hast du sollst du aber eigentlich
alles ist relativ klassisch dann muss
dazu sagen dass jetzt das achte
grundrezept also einfacher simpler weiß
einfache tomatensoße und chicken hier
haben wir unseren chat mit
insgesamt eineinhalb zwei stunden bei
eingestecktem mir sicher das wird
traditionell würde man das jetzt mit der
hand essen aber irgendwie weiß ich nicht
so recht zu fuß habe ich schon mit der
hand gegessen aber nämlich oder wenn ich
das mit nur dafür esse ich will jetzt
nicht falsch machen oder so glaube allen
voran haben wir dann richtig schöne
schärfe note drin mit der habanera und
joggt man halt nicht
[Musik]
über einen krank intensiver geschmack
der mir wirklich nicht viel zeit
hinzugefügt aber es ist schön wie kant
dazu hinten raus und eine leichte
schärfe note fruchtige tomaten lose
crazy viel geschmack passt sehr gut
zusammen freunde feierabend möglich dies
so intensiv ich habe sie immer noch in
meinem mund aber ich denke beim
abendessen erwartet dass mal was
besonderes wir besuchen jetzt wiki
unseren alten freund er zaubert extra
etwas germanisches für uns und ich kann
es kaum erwarten es uns gemeinsam also
leute ihr merkt schon wir sind hals über
kopf hier angekommen wir sind bei ricky
natürlich astra agro food ja es gibt auf
jeden fall jetzt ins mit planten könnten
ist einfach kochbananen
kommen ja die rote schultasche von
kumba system das kommt auch mal die
haben wir heute mit gefällt das typisch
richtig los ich guck mal da richtig
produkt auf ghana
ich finde das natürlich kommt
[Applaus]
es hier manchmal damals einig zunimmt
und kochen vortrag vorbereitet habe
zuvor bereits definitiv wir werden
nochmal weiter rechnen meint el tri team
ich habe den preis natürlich so aus dass
andere angst regieren kann ein politiker
scheiden man das kino heißt anders die
fed wird besser so das ist ein bisschen
komisch
klar ist so fußball
nur einmal wie sage ich würde heute
kommt jemand bereit ist das ganze noch
einmal unter
rein
hier wird gezaubert hier wird nicht
geklagt weil das so wie ich
gleichmacherei ist das wetter
[Gelächter]
spielt uns
damals in nigeria habe ja so kleines
kind nur gegessen aber das ist kann er
oder nigeria steht da muss ich mich an
hessen wobei sie nicht in die videos mit
antichrist beim mittagessen sich noch
nicht getraut mich
frisch gestrichen
[Musik]
beste herrn sorge macht macht ein bild
wird dann nimmst du
mit diesem
okay da wächst das ganze auch mal ein
paar hände sauber machen und her erst
mal ein bisschen kochbanane ein bisschen
wiens mit du
ich hab das gerade durch gesehen ich
habe die die zutaten gesehen dass wir
sehen wie es das eigentlich nur gedauert
habe die kann dass man das doch krank
viel schmecken wenn diese kleinen diese
kleinen zutaten diese besonderen
brühwürfel das palmöl es werde durch
krass lecker de fantaisie kopfball
schmecken quasi wie danach nie viel
weniger süß ich finde ich auch die tat
hat das was mit den händen ist macht
idealerweise noch jubelt spaß das macht
voll spaß ja man muss einfach mal machen
und es macht und schmeckt ich will mir
auch ganz sicher kommt unbedingt mal
vorbei denn er auch dieses motto
probieren wollte das freiwerden
ehrenfeld verlinkt noch mal und immer
wieder eine freude ich würde fast sagen
das war's für das video zehn von zehn
blick danke dir
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wieder bis dahin
[Musik]